Let's go next to our caller from the three
eight five area code.
Who's calling today from three eight five?
Hi, David, this is Laura from Somerville,
Mass.
Laura in Somerville.
Laura, tell me.
Let me ask a question.
Let me ask you something.
What's going on with my favorite Somerville
Cafe Diesel Cafe?
I obviously have not been there since the
start of the pandemic.
Are they doing OK?
I think so.
Oh, during a lot of just take out.
Got it.
OK.
Well, I hope to get back there when things
normalize.
Yeah, so my question is about the if you're
following the primary race here and in Massachusetts,
the Kennedy Markey, kind of, what are your
thoughts on that registar?
So, listen, I have friends that are working
on both campaigns, the reelection campaign
for Ed Markey and the challenge campaign for
for Kennedy.
And I have to tell you, I am very strongly
leaning towards Markey.
It's not obvious to me that Kennedy is, you
know, some progressive hero of any kind.
He strikes me as relatively establishment.
I don't know that there's much benefit to
replacing a senior senator with someone who
would be the lowest on the totem pole in a
legislative body like the Senate, where seniority
matters so much.
I believe that the debate was very bad for
Kennedy and Markey did very well.
So I'm just not seeing if I'm if I want to
make a change.
It needs to be super clear to me that we're
making a change for the better.
And I'm just I'm not at all convinced of that
right now.
OK.
Yeah, that's kind of where I've been.
I've lived here for 10 years and I moved here.
I mean, Marcie is always seemed to be on the
right side of things from a progressive standpoint.
So just curious where you were with that.
So the other thing that I've not loved about
the Kennedy ads is this idea that it's his
time sort of just making an age case where,
like, he's younger than Markey and it's in
now to replace older Democrats with younger
Democrats.
And that that I don't find that to be particularly
good reasoning, particularly when you're talking
about, again, losing the seniority that Ed
Markey has.
So I've been a little turned off by those
ads.
Right.
Well, and also kind of that idea of something
near when he's a Kennedy, like, let's not
forget that part.
That's a fair amount as well.
Yeah.
And I you know, I don't care so much about
that, but I think that that's a reasonable,
reasonable point as well.
All right.
OK, well, thanks.
Thank you for the call.
And I hope to be back up inside a real soon.
Appreciate it.
Thank you.
Let's see if we can hear from our caller from
the two oh six area code.
Who's calling today from two 06.
Does that me?
Yes, it is.
Hello.
Yes.
This is the myth.
This is the misanthropic curmudgeon from Seattle.
OK, can you maybe just be don't quite yell
so much into the phone, and I think we're
going to hear you fine.
OK, can you hear me now?
Yes.
That's better.
OK.
I actually had a couple of statements and
then a question.
OK.
The first statement is that thanks to Trump,
I think we now officially live in that asshole
country between Canada and Mexico.
Right.
And my other statement is that I believe a
free country should be founded on integrity
and empathy with four fundamental foundations
of no harm, no take, no betrayal and no destruction.
OK, that that being said, what is a breaking
point with this unconstitutional criminality
that we are compelled to do something next
levels to take our country back?
Wait, wait.
So which unconstitutional criminality are
you referring to?
Or just in general with the corporations not
paying taxes, Mitch McConnell not pushing
through voter protections.
And I just the list is endless.
Okay.
I mean, I think the answer is Idaho with the
Portland the Portland federal age.
I mean, how much more will we endure this
tyranny right before it collapses?
Well, so what do you want to do about it?
Tell me what you what's your plan?
Well, I'd like to see national initiatives
where we actually hear from the people, you
know, on what they want on a national level
instead of state by state.
OK.
And then what kind of actions would you like
to see, are you talking about mass rallies,
mass call outs from work, strategic defaults?
What are we what are you thinking of?
Well, my understanding, the way they come
through is supposed to work is we elect people
to represent us.
But what has happened, in essence, is we are
less likely people to overlord over us.
And that's I think the fundamental problem
is we don't have a representative government.
The government does whatever it wants and
we just have to take it.
Well, we can rukun we can go like someone
else, right?
We could vote in someone else.
Except that once you get someone in, as in
the case of Trump, then he's there.
What he does.
You know, he's duly elected this and due process
that.
But he he's a racist.
All of that with his contemptuous, unconstitutional,
tyrannical behavior.
Well, we've got to remove him in three months
then.
Right.
I did hear that.
We've got to remove him in three months then
for sure.
Yes, but there's still the residual of the
Mitch McConnell, the Steve Manoogian.
Absolutely.
Well, listen.
Check out my video.
Trump ism doesn't end when Trump leaves, because
that's exactly the heart of of what I'm getting
at.
Listen, I appreciate the call.
I think your questions that you're asking
some big questions.
They may be even too big for me, but I think
you're thinking about a lot of the right things.
Thanks to everybody who called in.
And as always, I apologize.
I'm not able to take every phone call.
We're going to take a break and we will be
back right after this.